When it comes to the Sith, the big bad villains
of the Star Wars universe, there's more than
one way to skin a Jedi.
Some Sith were strong in the force, while
others wielded sinister magic, or huge political
influence.
So who comes out on top when you add it all
up?
Here are the most powerful Sith ever...
Freedon Nadd
Freedon Nadd was a Jedi in the days of the
Old Republic, with Force talents far beyond
any of his peers.
While training, he became jealous of his Jedi
master's power and authority, so in true Sith
fashion, he killed him and renounced his affiliation
with the Jedi — man, what a baby.
"I hate you"
Nadd was trained in the ways of the Dark Side
by Naga Sadow (nahguh s’dao), a Sith lord
living in exile.
After his death, Freedon Nadd's ghost continued
to manipulate events from beyond the grave.
Marka Ragnos (Ragnus)
Marka Ragnos was a Sith Lord who grew tired
of the Sith's unwillingness to expand beyond
their homeworld of Korriban (Korrabun).
His reign was ruthless and brutal, but most
of the time, he achieved victory without raising
a finger.
A master of manipulation, Ragnos set his adversaries
against one another, using their mutually
assured destruction to clear an easy path
for the Sith.
And his story didn't end with his death either:
as a Force ghost, he pitted Sith Lords against
each other for the honor of becoming the official
Dark Lord.
"You will kneel before me, Jedi."
Darth Bane
Darth Bane is the Star Wars expanded universe's
version of a Founding Father when it comes
to the Dark Side of the Force.
As the last surviving member of the Sith Brotherhood
of Darkness, Bane started a new Sith Order,
and decided to pass his knowledge onto a single
apprentice, establishing the Rule of Two that
the Sith Lords have followed ever since.
"The Sith killed each other, victims of their
own greed.
But from the ashes of destruction I
was the last survivor.
I chose to pass my knowledge on to only one."
Darth Vader
As Anakin Skywalker, the man who would become
Darth Vader was expected to become the most
powerful Force user of all time, as he had
the highest midi-chlorian count ever recorded.
"I heard Yoda talking about midi-chlorians.
I've been wondering, what are midi-chlorians?"
Uhhh, let's not get into that.
But anyway, after massacring the students
of the Jedi Academy, Anakin was severely wounded
by his master Obi-Wan Kenobi, and as the cyborg
Vader, he lost some of his connection to the
Force.
Still, he had perhaps the most impressive
power of all: terrifying generations of moviegoers.
"I find your lack of faith disturbing."
Darth Nihilus (Nigh-h’luss)
The Dark Side of the Force can be seen as
a metaphor for addiction.
Darth Nihilus offers a perfect example.
After he was caught in the detonation of the
super-weapon known as the Mass Shadow Generator,
which destroyed the planet Malachor V (five),
Nihilus' body was wrecked.
He was left with an insatiable craving for
Force energy — essentially turning him into
a Force vampire.
Yikes.
Revan (Revvin)
Like so many other Sith, Revan also started
as a Jedi.
He turned to the Dark Side after the Jedi
Council refused to protect the lives of Outer
Rim innocents caught in the Mandalorian Wars.
Over their objections, Revan assembled at
large Jedi defense team, helping the Republic
win the war, but leading him down the dark
path to corruption.
He eventually embraced the light side again
and helped defeat the Sith.
"I've known both sides of the force, light
and dark."
Darth Sidious
Better known to most fans as Emperor Palpatine,
Darth Sidious rose to power thanks to ruthless
cunning.
After murdering his master, Darth Plagueis
(Playgus) , the Emperor hid in plain sight
as the benevolent galactic senator from Naboo.
Secretly orchestrating the Clone Wars, which
allowed him to consolidate political power,
Darth Sidious corrupted Anakin Skywalker and
virtually wiped the Jedi out of existence,
turning the tables after thousands of years
of Jedi dominance over the Sith.
"I'm afraid the deflector shield will be quite
operational when your friends arrive."
Darth Plagueis
Darth Plagueis wasn't the most skilled Force
user, nor was he a military leader, or particularly
good with a lightsaber.
Instead, Plagueis was a scholar and a scientist,
who focused his scholarly efforts on a single
pursuit: how to manipulate the Force and midi-chlorians
in a way that would allow him to live forever
and possibly even bring the dead back to life.
"Darth Plagueis was a dark lord of the Sith
so powerful and so wise that he could use the
force to influence the midi-chlorians to create
life."
With control over life itself, Plagueis feared
only one thing: losing his power.
Which he did when his apprentice, Darth Sidious,
killed him in his sleep.
Some fans theorize, however, that Plagueis
has returned in Star Wars: The Force Awakens
as the evil Sith lord Snoke.
Sounds like bad news for Rey!
"Bring her to me."
Darth Vitiate (Vishit)
The original Emperor, Darth Vitiate tricked
the other Sith Lords into helping him perform
a ritual that allowed him to absorb the life
force of every other living being on his home
planet.
The ritual granted Vitiate immortality and
immense power, which he used to found a galaxy-spanning
Sith Empire, ruling it with an iron fist for
1300 years.
"I have forged this empire to surmount all
of my previous works.
To span eternity."
Yeah, Palpatine had his moments for a few
decades, but when it comes to Sith Emperor's,
there's really no contest.
You can't beat a dude with 1300 years under
his belt…
"I am awakened and I bring with me, death."
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know which
sith lord you think is the most powerful ever…